obviously we're looking at the the
the issues that are raised by
vaccination certification
what can you do now in aviation clearly
there
uh lots of countries are thinking about
using uh some sort of vaccine
passport uh and i think that there are
three
basic components uh there's there's the
vaccine
uh there's your immunity that you might
have after you've had
uh covid and then there's testing so
there are three things that could
uh work uh together uh no decisions have
been taken at all one thing i will make
clear is none of this
is obviously going to apply uh on april
the 12th when
uh it will all be outdoors anyway so so
whatever happens
uh april the 12th will be uneffective
but just to be clear
to from what you're saying that you are
considering that you either will need a
test
or a vaccination and proof of that to go
indoors into a pub
well past may the 17th well all
sorts of things are being considered i
really think it's a bit premature
uh to start talking about that what we
want to do
is is roll out the vaccine program and
see what
that builds in terms of general
resistance to uh
to the uh to the virus and i do think
there is going to be there is going to
be a role
when will we know because the public
certificate
what we said is that we'll be reporting
on the the work of the
the certification uh group uh in early
april either on april 5th or on april
12th so there will be a role for
certification but it might just be for
international travel it could be for
pubs and agencies i think we need to
think carefully about the issues as i've
said before there are lots of difficult
issues because there are some people who
uh you know who for medical reasons
can't get a vaccination
pregnant women can't get a vaccination
uh
at the moment you know you've got to be
careful about how you you do this and
you might need to you
you might only be able to implement a
thorough going
uh vaccination passport scheme even if
you wanted such a thing
in the context of you know when
absolutely everybody
had been offered a vaccine